el impacto es inminente y Florida se
prepara para la llegada del huracán Ian
que continúa intensificándose a medida
que avanza hacia territorio
estadounidense tras haber generado caos
en Cuba
se espera que toque tierra siendo
categoría 4 en la costa oeste del Estado
los habitantes de Charlotte instalan
barreras para proteger sus negocios y
hogares
Estuve aquí en 2004 perdí mi negocio en
2004 debido a Charlie Ese es el negocio
de mi hija así que es un déjà Vu Así que
esto es tratar de salvar lo que podamos
salvar y lo que aprendimos desde la
primera vez
otros preparan sus automóviles para
alejarse del peligro lo más importante
es no entrar en pánico el pánico es lo
peor el mismo panorama se vive en
grandes ciudades como Tampa en donde las
largas filas marcan el panorama de sus
carreteras las autoridades han llamado
evacuar a más de 2,5 millones de
personas en toda Florida
un pedido que reiteró la agencia Federal
para el manejo de emergencias asegurando
que podría marcar la diferencia entre la
vida y la muerte por su parte el
gobernador de Florida ron de santis se
dirigió a los ciudadanos el martes en la
tarde y alertó sobre los riesgos que
podría conllevar el huracán
en general la gente está tomando las
precauciones adecuadas
cuando observa una marejada ciclónica de
esta naturaleza Es un peligro que pone
en riesgo la vida cuando habla de tres o
cuatro metros de marejada ciclónica que
podría haberse en ciertas partes cuando
toque tierra
[Música]
el presidente Joe biden se refirió a Ian
y lo catálogo de muy Severo y
potencialmente mortal el mandatario
habló con el gobernador de Florida para
definir los pasos para hacerle frente al
huracán de manera conjunta